hace unas pocas horas que ha llegado a
las costas de estambul el barco carguero
con bandera de sierra leona pero que
partió ayer por la mañana del puerto de
odessa el carguero como decíamos razón y
que está ahora mismo esperando en la
desembocadura del estrecho del bósforo
en el mar negro para poder transitar
esta vía marítima una de las más famosas
del mundo no podrá hacerlo hasta que el
contenido del carguero que es de trigo y
grano exportado desde los silos de
ucrania sea inspeccionado por el centro
de coordinación conjunta establecido
hace algo más de una semana en estambul
con la participación de turquía y
naciones unidas como mediadoras en este
pacto que al que llegaron rusia y
ucrania rusia y ucrania que también
están representadas en este centro de
coordinación en estambul que abrió la
semana pasada varios miembros de este
comité irán mañana por la mañana a las 8
de la mañana hora de turquía sobre las
12 de la noche hora de bogotá a
investigar el contenido de este carguero
razón y en caso de que ucrania no mienta
como se espera que sea así que el
contenido de este el contenido de este
carguero es únicamente trigo él se
permitirá a partir de mañana
a mediodía por la mañana que el razón y
transite esta vía del estrecho del
bósforo para llegar primero al asecho de
los dardanelos después en dirección al
mar egeo pasando después por el mar
mediterráneo destino final trípoli en el
líbano un país muy necesitado del trigo
y del grano que lleva este este carguero
por una que es grave crisis alimenticia
que vive no sólo él iba no sé también
muchos países de áfrica y de oriente
próximo por el alto precio del trigo y
el grano que empezó sobre todo a
dispararse tras la invasión de rusia en
ucrania en febrero desde 2000 22